if you are ingesting large amount of
data for analysis or looking to simplify
the development of event-driven
applications then you need to check out
cloud FAFSA
[Music]
in the last couple episodes we learnt
about cloud pub/sub through cat outs
asynchronous order processing website we
saw how pops-up helps manage the
interactions between order packaging
shipping and notification services in
today's episodes let's build a cloud
pub/sub system for cata as seen in the
last episode for cat outs application
the whole system will comprise of three
topics corresponding to order packaging
and shipping service for the sake of
understanding let's only consider the
order service sending messages to
packaging and notification service and
build that part of the system
feel free to extend this further and
build the whole flow alright so we will
have a publisher application order
service which sends a simple message
order received this message gets sent to
two subscribers the packaging service
and a notification service which process
the message and then these services
process and send the message forward to
their topics and subscribers to complete
the order flow and process the order
fully okay so now that we know what we
are building we are going to build this
in four steps let's start with step one
where we will create the cloud pub/sub
topic for the order service and the two
subscriptions for packaging and
notification service if you are new to
Google cloud create a free account by
navigating to cloud google.com slash
free and following the instructions
there then navigate to the console and
create or use an existing project make
note of the project ID now let's
navigate to the cloud pub/sub section of
the console and click on create a topic
let's call this topic order underscore
topic our order service which is our
publisher will send messages to this
topic then scroll down on the create
topic and click on create subscription
let's name the first subscription as
package underscore sub leave the rest as
default which will create a pull
subscription
we use the same procedure to create
another subscription attached to the
order topic called notifications up at
this point your cloud pub/sub
environment is ready with the order
topic and the two subscriptions now we
are on to step two where we will create
a service account that the applications
use for authentication and setup cloud
iam permissions navigate to service
accounts section of the console and
click create service account enter a
service account names such as pub
subsystem and click create for this
example the service account needs
publishing and subscribing permissions
so we use the select a rouble drop-down
to add the cloud pub/sub publisher and
cloud pub/sub subscriber role click
continue and we do not need to grant
user access to their to this service
account then create key this key is used
by the client library to access the
cloud pub/sub API select JSON and click
create the key is sent to the downloads
folder for the purpose of this demo we
can leave it there and rename the key
file to key dot JSON now the next step
is to start the three independent
applications one publisher which is our
order service and two subscribers which
are our packaging and notification
service for this step we need the Google
Cloud SDK installed if you don't have it
today's the day to download it if you're
not already in the pub sub project on
Google Cloud SDK then set the project
using g-cloud config set project list
the topics to see the order topic we
created from the console and list
subscriptions to see the packaging and
notification subscriptions if you don't
have python this would be a great point
to install python and setup virtual
environment using the steps in the
description below create a folder where
you want to download the sample python
files for this demo CD into it and
download the code now open three new
terminals one for our order publisher
and two for our subscribers in these
terminals create a Python virtual
environment and activate it upgrade the
Google cloud pub/sub in all three
terminals
associate the json key with the service
account created earlier now set up an
environment variable with our current
project ID we use the g-cloud command to
determine currently selected project ID
and set it as the project variable
verify that the project variable is set
to our current project ID CD into the
directory with sample code and get into
our publisher file pub dot py change the
message from HelloWorld to order
received now we are ready to send
messages let's start our packaging
subscriber now which is listening and
our order publisher our order
application sent an order received
message with a message ID while being
unaware of any existing subscriptions
the packaging subscriber application
receives the order received message and
prints it and sends an acknowledgement
to cloud pub/sub pops up receives this
acknowledgement which indicates that the
message has been processed successfully
and does not need to be resent to the
packaging subscriber cloud pub/sub then
removes the message from that subscriber
backlog now let's start the notification
subscriber and as soon as it is started
it receives the message published by the
order topic the difference here is that
this subscriber isn't started until
after the publisher has sent the message
to the topic and subscriptions if the
notification service was called directly
from the order service then the message
would either have to wait a long time or
timeout since this service was not
available cloud pub/sub manages this
process by effectively saving the
message for the order notification
subscription today we built a simple
cloud pub/sub system and not how it
sends messages from a publisher to a
subscriber at this point you should be
able to build a simple application with
cloud pub/sub in the upcoming videos we
will cover more important details and
choices you will need to make when
building a real-world application that's
all for today on pops-up made easy join
us next time to check out a deep dive
into publishers if you liked this video
and would like
see more such content don't forget to
like and subscribe to our Channel
[Music]